good morning everyone and can I welcome
everyone to development control
committee a of midst of a District
Council just before we start just need
to run through some of the domestic
arrangements first of all the WCS are
situated outside the meeting room
opposite the lifts and stairs there's
also cold waters available in the
breakout area the firearm does sound can
you please leave the council chamber by
following the fire exit signs and we
need to gather at Ipswich Town Football
Club training pitch please do not
re-enter the building until we're told
it is safe to do so can ask everyone
just to double-check your mobile phones
are switched off or at least on silent
if they do ring it's a donation to the
Chairman's charity is our tradition I'd
like to remind everyone present that the
meeting we broadcast live on the
internet and will be capable of repeated
viewings the whole of the meeting will
be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items if you make a
representation to this meeting you'll be
deemed by the council to have consented
to being filmed and to the possible use
of those images and sound recordings for
webcasting and/or training purposes the
council members of the public and press
may record film or photograph or
broadcast broadcast this meeting when
the public and press are not lawfully
excluded and finally Qaida's asked
members and officers when we speak -
please Mitchell we do turn the
microphone on and turn it off when we're
finished just for the benefit of some
members of the public who may not be
familiar with the way we operate just do
some introductions on my right are the
council's district councillors elected
councillors and myself will make a
decision on the applications before us
today and then starting on my right we
have in depressed
who's our legal advisor then we have sit
on my left we have officers who make
everything work on time and schedule and
make sure everything is broadcast
correctly and on the back and on my
right is Gemma and the team of the
planning officers who present the
applications before us today and then
finally in mid suffer
you may speak on an application in your
ward but you may not vote on it so if
that's the case you'll be asked to sit
on the other side of the chamber and you
may speak but as I said not vote think
that covers the basics so moving on to
the agenda first item is apologies for
absence and substitutions please Thank
You chair we have apologies from
councillor Turner
and council of all boys is substituting
today thank you do you need to receive
any decorations to Pecunia non-pecuniary
interest by members Oh hands going up
yeah councillor having younger than
customer Dunedin market when I'm on
their mid Suffolk but a great board in
my case I'm the vice chair of stow
market Town Council Planning Committee
and we've previously discussed item 7e
nope
just for the record item number DC 1903
one nine one which is six Church Street
in I has been withdrawn and is not
before us today thank you any
decorations of lobbying nope none
receipt thank you any decorations of
personal site visits by members no thank
you
if we can now turn to the minutes of the
previous meeting which within your
papers oh they're tabled sorry yes then
the lake that this table of papers if
you can just have a quick look at those
and if I just run through them and it
only points with you feeling not a cure
if you just raise your hand page 1 page
2 page 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 and page 10 can I
sign this as a true record of the
meeting is that agreed agreed
thank you I'll do that after the meeting
[Applause]
right so we now need to receive
notification of petitions in accordance
with the councilors petition scheme are
there any place none received here on
then - the first item the schedule of
planning applications the first planning
application before us today is DC 1905
166 Needham lake goblin Road need a
market start on page 9 of our papers
over - Gemma could present the
application Thank You chair morning
members yes this is an application for a
visitor at Needham Lakes at that one
sorry okay so this is the application
site just to the west west of the main
road that comes down and it's needed
markets and we've got some them site
photos in in a minute which will show
that bit more again the application site
with some constraints on we can just see
the two in yellow are great - listed
buildings and then as we come down the
road here we're looking at coming into
need and market but I said I've got some
areas just to show that a bit better the
site is within the flood zone and we
have had comments from the Environment
Agency which I'll probably this a bit
more information on as we get to those
points and then again it is within close
proximity to some triple si and
landscape area designations but overall
the site itself either outside of those
and not considered to risk particular
harm but again I'll I'll come on to that
so this is the site itself the a
location of the building will be in here
we've got the mustard pot veterinary
surgery itself in there and then we're
coming down towards the listed
footbridge and the mill to the south of
the site through here and then again
it's slightly further out we can see the
lengths to either side this is the
needle Nate carbine for members who may
be familiar with that that's used on the
Wednesday and Saturday for coffee and
that shares the same access as the sites
and in the wider carpark area for access
to Needham links itself and then just a
zoomed out version just to show where we
are in conjunction so and
this the parish this one is creating sit
memory but essentially it's on the on
the border with neither market and and
said neither makes itself this is the
existing site plan we can see there are
a couple of existing buildings on site
which census of the ice cream and
concession that is proposed for removal
and then we look at the proposed site
plan a new surface through to access
here with the building with service
access to the rear and then also access
off the footpaths the front of the
building through here looking out onto
the fly area and down towards the river
and then we've got a 3d vision of it
there what it looks like so we're
looking at a single story building with
a mono pitched roof the sort of main
frontage of building is set back under
that roof so we've got some outdoor
seating to the front and that also
provides some shading to the interior of
the building and then elevations again
for members that we can see we're
looking at solar panels to the roof as
well and again outside elevations there
the building is predominately to provide
a visitor center but it's a combination
visitor center and cafe with a mixed-use
space with a proposal to have flexible
options inside includes access to the
toilets design so that can provide
multiple options whether the cafe is the
center or open or not that's within
control there is also a changing places
facility in there for disabled
facilities whether a cafe in kitchen we
can see the service area to the rear and
there's also various outdoors servicing
and storage for the cafe and visitor
center and that outdoor seating but it's
under the cover through that area that
which looks out onto the existing play
area now here we can see sections
through the building these are here
because the silent as I mentioned is
within the flood zone three so it is an
area liable to flooding and we have had
a lot of discussions with the
Environment Agency about this there has
been a flood risk assessment provided
and the building is shown lifted above
the floodplain so that
it's lifted there'll be a void
underneath the Environment Agency have
confirmed that they have no objection to
this proposal subject to there being a
condition to ensure that the void is
maintained so essentially that void
underneath doesn't get silted up or
blocked up so it would affect the
functional floodplain provided that
that's something we felt we're happy to
see by condition they were raising their
objection to the proposal and I'm
content to do that by means of condition
so overall although yes it is floodplain
because of what has been provided that
because it has been lifted up above what
is expected to be the flood levels and
this mitigation provided work intended
that wouldn't pose an unacceptable risk
and then just some site photos so this
is the entrance to need amongst itself
and looking down with the mustard pot
and I will write it down
essentially in towards need to market
and then back this way we're looking up
towards this history gay 14 Junction
would be up there if we carried on up
the road and then active suits the site
itself with the Kabu entrance and exit
on light and again we can see some of
the parking that's there there's no
proposed changes to any of the parking
and then again we come through the
access road onto the neither makes car
park these are some of the existing
structures which would it be expected to
be removed and the building itself would
be just feeling for that point and again
so we can see the existing play area and
then we're looking through it the blue
stick male and the footbridge is just
sort of essentially underneath us as
well and then again just towards the
lakes in this case which we can see the
existing path there and there would be
another pathway up through here to our
left and then again this is essentially
on the bridge so we're looking down
again at the listed male and the
separation between the site and the mill
we have had comments from heritage to
accept that while it is essentially
within its setting because of the design
character and appearance of the building
it's not considered to result in any
harm to that listed building or in terms
of the listed structures in here and
then again so we're on that that part of
that listed
structure here looking towards the site
up here see you know it's a reasonable
distance away I think that's my heritage
you've accepted combined with the design
not to cause any harm and then again
looking back across this is looking
through to the mustard pot veterinary
surgery there's a fairly substantial
hedge right there at the moment
obviously with wind so we're not getting
a lot of the foliage on it but it's
there there's no proposal to affect that
or to tape make any changes to check
that hands right and then again we're
essentially stood on the site so you can
see how it links to the play area but it
does remain some separation to that mill
building and then looking across the the
carpark this really the edge of the
building wound and then again just to
come back to that 3d visual view for
members that essentially this is a
visitor center to support needham
lengths we consider it's got benefits to
the tourism and economy so it's links to
need to market to support that existing
recreational use don't consider it's got
harm in respect of the flood zones
heritage neighbor amenity or highway
safety and therefore the recommendations
for approval thank you Joe thank you
very much
questions yes Castlefield
just about you you show solar panels on
the roof they seem they're not visible
in the 3d pictures and they seem to be
an incredibly low angle are they really
going to be effective or was it just a
bit of greenwash but I haven't got any
information about how effective or
otherwise they would be it's not
something we would seek per se for this
kind of building we have suggested a
condition to make sure they implement
their renewable energy scheme because
they have got a whole scheme in place
more than just just the solar panels
potentially what they would add I can't
confirm what when they come forward okay
Kassem awesome thank you I too was going
to ask about the solar panels because
the roof slopes to the north so I was a
bit concerned about the efficiency of
them and then I spotted on your enlarged
that they are slightly tilted but that
doesn't work an optimum angle but I'm
interested in your response because
section 4.2 on page 16 and 17 does say
that solar panels are proposed
so one assumes that that is what we are
granting permission for but anyway I'll
leave the solar panels to the applicant
what I would like to ask is has there
been any consideration of rainwater
harvesting for you to the toilets I
don't think I've had any information on
rainwater harvesting proposed but again
perhaps that something we the applicant
can give some more information on there
there is there is in the condition
something about a water but and I
wondered if that had anything to do with
it
okay so in the third risk assessment
that's proposed it mentions water but
that doesn't kind of confirm whether
that is part of strategy or is not part
of the strategy and given the benefits
of water but can offer are so it seemed
sensible to secure that by way of
condition so that's related to the
overall drainage of the site rather than
its reuse yeah thank you I just was
going to sort of expand on a bit there's
some concerns raised about the location
of the center because it's not close to
the current parking for blue badge
holders so the concern was about the the
width of the paths and this the surface
materials for people in wheelchairs
could access the center so it's there
isn't any blue band parking on the
Needham like site as it stands the the
parking is essentially not marked out
the only space that is marked on that
site is for the electric vehicle
charging point otherwise there's not
essentially marked at all and that is
outside of the red line of what we're
looking at whether that's something that
we could take away separately in terms
of the applicant being in Suffolk that
they could mark that out and I suppose
where the planning would come to is the
fact that this is to support that
current least areas currently that
parking and or proposing any changes to
it and then with respect to the path
we've had
the motion of the materials because also
our waste team were concerned about
wheeling the buildings along the paths
and what they would be like I had a
confirmation of change to the materials
so it will essentially be a smooth
surface to allow access along with the
path and these service access Thank You
Irma my question relates to a comment
made by the mid suffered disability
forum regarding the facilities available
for severely disabled people notably
would there be a hoist and an
adult-sized chaining bed in the disabled
facility I think we might have to just
confirm that with the applicant this is
what they have said to us is it will be
a changing places facility to provide
that level what that actually entails
I hope they can just confirm what that
exactly extends to Casa filter just one
more line and paragraph eight one talks
about flood zones three and then goes on
to talk about flood zone 3b I'm not
familiar with the difference and so the
flood zone three gets divided by
ourselves as the local planning
authority rather than run into C into 3a
and 3b essentially three beers
functional floodplains and the
expectation is 3b would flood and needs
to provide for that so the understanding
we have with the involved agency
following various discussions with them
is we should expect this site to flood
and therefore would how do we mitigate
for that would this be appropriate and
we've had that conversation with the
Environment Agency that said that's
where why their proposal has got that
increase in the floor level to lift it
above potential flood level and then
provide for the flood to go underneath
off the building does that so it's once
every two or three years sort of thing
not once every two or three hundred
years
yeah it's potentially it's more regular
than the once in a hundred years or with
climate change differences it's more
like
but it is part of the functional
floodplain but you have to endure
climate change differences into account
up there yep so we've run this tool past
the Environment Agency because initially
they were concerned and we had their
objection a holding objection we've gone
through various discussions with them
and I know the flood risk consultant
from the applicant has discussed that in
detail with the Environment Agency I
sorry
and then we've had this subsequent
agreement from the Environment Agency
they were content with what the
mitigation provides for thank you any
other questions so this hasn't got any
Brienne status or anything like that no
that it is what has been offered for
this building offering something with
low impact on this site both in terms of
the design and materials and putting
forward a variety of measures for it but
no it hasn't got any specific status
primarily because of its small floor
space we'd only normally seek that over
a thousand square meters in policy terms
but they have offered a reasonable
package and we have secured that by way
of condition any other questions
No okay so we'll move on we don't have
the the Town Council here we don't have
an object or a supporter but we do have
the applicant Danny Hughes like to come
up and take a fine you have three
minutes we have a timer here we do ask
you to keep to the three minutes please
good morning and having reviewed the
planners assessment of the application
and the committee report I'm very
comfortable that the officer has
captured all aspects of the project
Needham Lake is a really exciting
project to be involved with but it's
also a feel-good project we as a design
team acknowledge that Needham Lake is a
heavily visited destination
predominantly for its beauty and
Wildlife is therefore not surprising
that the council and local community
want the visitor center to be
sympathetic to surroundings and that's
what we strive to do they propose a
statics of the building or in harmony of
the lake their building is predominantly
timber by structure and cladding and as
such provides natural and organic visual
many of the materials used and
operational ethos within the building
lean towards that of more of a
sustainable solution the designers also
listened in 2018 the council issued a
questionnaire which called for the
community's opinion of what the new
visitor center should be the output of
that questionnaire proved to be a
valuable briefing document which was at
the heart of our project as we move
forwards initial concept designs were
then presented at a public engagement
event in October this year where the
proposals were very much appreciated we
have listened to the request for
changing places toilet and that's it's
been incorporated and I think the team
of knowledge that's the right thing to
do
we've listened to those who like to use
the lake for dog walking and we've
incorporated a course extension to the
building so those who have dogs can
still benefit from the facilities of the
center the center has been designed to
not be limited to any single use and it
is adaptable and it can evolve through
changing needs and changing community
demands we feel that the design responds
well to the brief we were given and is a
fitting conclusion to all the design
iterations that we've undertaken thank
you very much thank you
Casa master Jules go first with your
question yeah well I I I wanted to ask
about the efficiency of the solar panels
given that the roof is facing in
slightly northwards I'd also like to ask
was there ever any consideration of
rainwater harvesting for use in the
toilets okay so on the solar panels yeah
we acknowledge you right that it's
facing the wrong way
effectively we're currently in the
process of firming up that designs we're
going through the detailed design part
at the moment so I think within that
process we will naturally lean towards
ways to make it more efficient
that would include framing solutions to
lift it off so it changed the angle off
the roof angle is one way we can have
frames on there to angle it the other
way and we also look at the technology
of the solar panels and some work better
in slightly shaded areas and I do
acknowledge that an overall limitation
is that it is still facing the wrong way
so it will have a natural benefit this
summer more than the winter and that we
are doing all we can to make it as
efficient as possible for the soda and
rainwater harvesting was considered and
I don't think it's completely off the
table we looked at various ways of
treating the the gray water matter
coming out from the toilet and either
waste one of the options of so that the
site initially has limitations over
accessibility to drainage and so we
looked at keeping drainage and arisings
on-site and dealing with those but being
in a floodplain the likelihood of
flooding we've had to compromise the
aspirations in that regard to what we
can t do and if a flood those happen
what happens to local water courses so
I've ever gets off the cards and indeed
I saw one of the draft conditions is
probably that of a water buck so we can
definitely explore that and and I think
the brief we've received from from the
council as our client is to make this
building as the sane of it as possible
within certain parameters so I think as
a comment would definitely explore that
anyone else I've got a cold yak a
similar jet it's just basically to
repeat the previous question I asked to
to Gemma bearing in mind what the myth
Suffolk disability forum have said about
the change in place of City which which
are welcome would it be possible to
equip that with a host voice trial and
an adult size change a bit for severely
disabled people to use yes is the answer
so we are looking at fully complying the
changing places category which includes
a hoist a changing bed a shower we're
going to include as an optional thing
we are looking to include that as well
as those physical features to comply of
changing places it's about the set out
and the layout of that as well so it
allows carers to operates of the beds in
the middle and as we're setting them out
so yes so we're looking to fully comply
with the changing place yeah counselor
field and cancel even odds he being
covered the issue of the solar panel is
whether it was just gonna point out that
clearly to get a reasonable output
they've got a point of the Sun when it's
been somewhere between the account
criteria and the northern tropic yeah
Capricorn is up and you know that's a
fixed unknown number so one knows what
angles they need to be an act it's fixed
boy God or physics or someone and the
pictures don't show that I'm very happy
with most of the pictures but it's just
a matter of these are a bit deceptive if
someone thinks that the solar panels are
gonna be that unobtrusive then they're
kidding themselves so it's a matter of
perception the concerns may be what's
your view on that and oh you're quite
right we don't want to add on these
technologies which are intended to be a
sustainable feature at the detriment of
the overall design intent honestly I'm I
don't know the answer that we're going
through the process and but I'm happy
for that to be fed back to the officer
as we evolve that design if there's a
need for them to to be undertaken and
but there there will definitely be from
the designers perspective they'll
definitely be an ambition to not allow
the solar powers to influence too far
the design intent and visuals that we've
created
how are you been and Thank You chair I'm
concerned about the lighting at the site
and particularly during winter months
and obviously we want to have us you
know darker skies as possible so I'm a
how can we be sure that I know this
conditions right around lighting but
that that is it the most efficient and
ensures that we have the darkest skies
possible in that location okay okay so
we can we have to come
as I suppose between lighting required
for the ease of access and safe access
and the safe management of this of the
building as an operation and taking that
forward so I weakened liaised with
design team with electrical engineers
who apparent in the process of designing
out that technical aspect and we can
start considering things like timers so
ever they're only on in operational
hours we can start considering the
angles of them that they are there to
illuminate paths not wider illumination
and so we can start being more specific
for now we just have a design intent
which is what was submitted and the next
few weeks are really finessing them so
we can take that away is quite useful
feedback and and I'll fill that back
that's okay a couple of questions for me
if I may what is the lifetime of the
building and when you have designed it
have you thought about keeping the
running costs as low as possible as this
a council asset first part that question
the second part absolutely so the
building talked about sustainability
generally there's many ways you can tick
sustainability boxes but what we tried
to do in the first instance design
sustainability from the heart of the
project so we start looking at fabric
first approaches so bolt ons are
secondary to installing things that that
really are sustainably narrow right so
that's why from Timbers sustainably
sourced it's low maintenance in its own
right we haven't got air conditioning
where we're opting to design in a stack
system calling which is where the
building physics cools at night so
there's high up windows and they will
expel warm air overnight allow cooled
air to come in and there's quite a
common feature in in Europe so we're
looking at those kind of things which
will in turn reduce maintenance costs it
will induce peak load so conditioning is
quite heavy on energy consumption so
with all of those features so our
aspirations for it to be a sustainable
building are then rippling through to
the ongoing maintenance management of
that and they will be very efficient
boilers there for example an air source
heat pump is gonna be used to primarily
heat the bill
and those go features for the same bit
do you know lifespan
the first year you're planning for at
least 30 I said the roof is on a 30 year
that kind of aligned with met warranties
yet for installers framers around 60
years there's not been a lot in the
Builder so you've got your internal
petitions which might need more
decorative maintenance as you go along
and that's fine thank you just wanted to
make sure it wasn't a ten year Porter
cabin design and Casa Mansell
so I thought of another question and
perhaps this is a bit of a personal
question really tend cycle storage
spaces are proposed I can't see them on
the plans but what I can see is a bike
leaning up against the pillars so I just
wondered where they on your sexual
buildings I just wonder where the bike
racks we're going to go
yeah that's probably just design intent
we've gone from gone mad but I believe
from memory there between the proposed
center location and the current car park
and there'll be a number of parking and
bike hoops then okay I think that's all
the questions thank you very much so we
have two board members for Needham
Market
the first is we have council Norris and
councillor Phillips our church in
alphabetical order so council Norris
first I'm unable to attend development
control committee meeting next Wednesday
please find my comments as a joint board
member in respect to this application
I'm wholly in support of this
application as it is a facility that has
been very much in demand for some time
with visitors to Needham Lake frequently
asking where they can obtain
refreshments etc there are many visits
to Needham laid by various groups
including school visits who benefit from
the facilities that will be on offer and
it will further enhance Needham Lake
which I now understand is the most
frequently visited free attraction in
the eastern region there is currently a
feasibility study being undertaking on
improving the access to Needham Lake and
also to need a market town centre valve
the railway station subway and if this
is successful it will not only improve
the access to the businesses and
resulting in higher football but will
also aid the local economy by increasing
the viability of the shots on the high
street and therefore very much in favor
of this project and I'm pleased that mid
suffer District Council has decided to
go ahead with it
Council Mike Norris needed Market Ward
then we also have a comment from
councillor Phillips I am unfortunate
unable to attend the above and
Development Control Committee meeting on
Wednesday the 11th of December so
pleased by my comments as the drawing
board member I'm holy and support of
this application there are many visits
to Needham Lakes by various groups
including school visits will benefit
from the facilities that will be on
offer and it will further enhance
Needham Lake which I understand is now
the most frequently visited pre
attraction in the eastern region as my
dry quard member Mike Norris has already
stated there is currently a feasibility
study being undertaken on improving the
access to Needham Lake and also to need
a market town center by the railway
station subway and if this is successful
it will not only improve the access to
the Visitor Center resulting in higher
football but it would also aid the local
economy by increasing the viability of
the shops on the high street
I'm very much in favor of this project
and I'm pleased that mr. Suffolk has
decided to go ahead with it you all
sincerely Steve Phillips so there's
that's the information from the ward
members so we've had everything put to
us or the information up to us to
discuss debate and come to a conclusion
who would like to go first
Castle war boys you were first up thank
answering I think we've got a very
elegant design proposal here I think it
would be an asset to need him like
something we're very happy to support it
there are a few concerns being raised
about disability access and the probably
intrusion into the design of the solar
panels but I think these are going to be
resolved by the design team so I think
it's very good proposal calorie burn
thank you very much chair mi-28 booth
support
of this application and I think because
it's something that MIT Suffolk
statement we really need to be very very
careful in terms of the approach
particularly in terms of sustainability
so we can show not just a local
community that the wider community
Howard Suffolk ur acting in terms of
designing buildings out for the future
so I'd be happy to support it but I very
much want to see strong sustainability
features being borne out during the
bills thank you
Casa Mountain thank you yes I'd like to
echo the comments for my my colleagues I
think I think it's fantastic that mid
Suffolk are developing this facility it
need to make I'm looking forward to
having a bike ride there and having a
cup of coffee
so yes I would very much like to support
it but I - you know do want it to have
the highest feasible sustainability
features in the design which is why I
asked the questions about the solar
panels and the rainwater harvesting and
I hope that the conditions that are
imposed on the on the the implementation
of those sustainability features is
going to to make sure that we do have a
an exemplar exemplary facility you know
to show that look we can have this low
carbon usage coffee shop visitor center
at Needham Lake so I'm very much in
support of it
so I'll propose that we go along with
the officer recommendation we're happy
with those conditions okay thank you
Casa Fiat yes I'm sure I support this
have to sell a little about two miles
from here so I'm sure I will visit it
when it gets constructed yeah and all
the benefits have been discussed the
only issue is that one about we're
putting solar panels on there you would
want that to draw the heat pump on a
good day so they really have to be
effective not just not just there to be
able to say that we've supplied them so
with that one caveat
suborders do you want to second it if it
hasn't been met anyone else wish to
speak from this yeah customer for fear
of repeating horse being said I'm
worried about solar panels
I think clunking I'm on top with a
north-facing ruth is clumsy the rest of
the design is excellent I don't see the
need for a north sloping roof so what
concerns me slightly is the the
condition that we can apply to this to
make sure that we don't get highly
ranked erect panels on top that look as
though they just been plunked on top as
an afterthought oh we better do some
sustainability so I'm concerned about
the design of that roof why does it need
to be north-facing okay anyone else wish
to speak nope so it's been proposed by
countless amounts of and sector by
accounts of the field and I think the
recommendations that are on page 22 are
quite light touch they're sort of more
headline but I think it's very clear
what members instructions are do we need
to elaborate a bit more just to get that
in the wording how do you want to pick
that up and yeah I think the reason
they're fairly light touches they have
come in with the information up front
whereas quite often we don't get much
information on penny impressions upfront
and therefore we condition all of it so
the majority of it is that they will
implement what they've said to us
noting members concerns about the
renewable energy is rather than an
acquire than the simple it's implement
what they're told us if members would
prefer a scheme to be submitted to us so
that essentially the Planning Officers
have fun or say that would be a fairly
minor change but would give us a little
bit of that control back if if that's
what would be satisfied with I think
we're so the important point of picking
up on the rainwater harvesting and what
happens with that a minutes it's it's
been raised so an additional condition
for rainwater harvesting scheme to be
great to be a great yeah
so you happy that counts amounts from
councilor fear I am I am happy with
rainwater harvesting scheme to be
investigated because if there are issues
with with water supply and the drainage
many variable I don't know that we can
impose a condition that they must do it
but I think it should be looked into to
see if it is feasible
yeah if this what was to be agreed okay
yeah I think if if we use the wording to
be agreed if they were to submit to us
as panel authority as Phelan says you
can't do it for these reasons and we
were satisfied that it would be a flood
zone issue or whatever issue we could
agree that there wouldn't be a scheme
but then we would know that it has been
considered so just to confirm so rather
than implementation of energy scheme we
it's that will be agreed and then the
rainwater scheme to be agreed if
feasible yeah yep okay
on that basis has been proposed by
Council amount assault and sector by
councilor field all those in favor the
recommendation with the additions of
comm page 22 and the extra points have
just been made well those in favor
that's unanimous
thank you very much now the next item do
ya
okay we'll stay with go straight on to
7b this is planning application DC
nineteen eighty three seven nine zero in
Hawley stay upwind and weathered endures
the ward and over to Catherine is going
to percent Thank You chair good morning
members
so this application is outline planning
permission with all matters reserved
safe for access which is to be
considered for up to 29 dwellings within
Hawley
so this is four constraints map as you
can see the cytosines of the top right
hand corner just outside the settlement
boundary there are no real constraints
although it should be noted that there
is a listed building just to sort of the
southwest to the site here this is a
site in the context obviously the
settlement boundary so the area shaded
green on the slide shows the existing
settlement boundary it does go further
for the west then I'll see the slide and
this is just in a context so you can
still see all the built up residential
area and then the agricultural fields to
the east so this is a redline site
location plan the site is one point two
eight hectares and this application has
been supported by corley Parish Council
on the basis that it is in the holy
parish neighborhood plan which was
adopted in October this year under
policy H a youth fall he actually
specifically states will see the land to
the at Station Road east of Mill fields
is basically an area that they think she
will see have development despite it
being out of a certain boundary
currently so this is just the proposed
map for neighborhood plan which
demonstrates the policy for the site
so within the current adopted local plan
it's outside the settlement boundary and
within the emerging draft joint local
plan which I'll see a cylinder
regulation regulation 18 and has limited
weight again would appear outside the
settlement boundary but the main
highlight here is the fact that I'll see
Hawley have designated that site for
development within their neighborhood
plan so as I stated previously it is
outline for all matters reserved other
than access however we have got an
indicative site layout and it's
understood that the reserved matters and
Orsi this outline if recommended and if
granted would have a condition stating
that the indicative layout will remain
as as demonstrated on this proposal here
this is like to show you the layout
within the context I'll see mill fields
which is to the west and then the
residential development to the south of
the site so here you've got just two
properties facing on to your C the
street and that the blue shows a
tree-lined Avenue as you enter you've
got a group of properties that are
native review into the green space so
you've got frontage aspects and all the
green spaces monitored the same down
here in this corner of the site and then
you've got another slightly larger
cluster and then there's slightly more
dispersed as you move out towards the
countryside at the north of the site
obviously because the agricultural
fields to north and the east at the
moment again as it's outlined only the
landscaping hasn't been agreed or or
discussed in any detail but it is noted
that when Rizzo matters do you know come
in the oven oven in the east and
boundaries will need to have careful
consideration as to how they're
addressed this just shows the access
arrangement the gray black dotted line
is where they're proposing to put the
new footpath so at the moment
runs up to mill fields at a point of the
arrow this proposal weird insular
footpath along with front of of the site
as well as connecting to the other side
of the road this one allows continuous
footpath straight down into holy centre
and as you can see from see this the all
the services and the site would be here
with a footpath that then joins up and
you cannot see walk straight there it's
a sight photo approaching from from east
as you head into holy site is just in
the distance roughly where this tree and
along here that's just a frontage so
moment there is a hedgerow it's not very
tall it's most of it will probably be
lost due to the access and visibility
space however see hopefully reserved
matters landscaping we can address and
look to reinstate a green edge towards
the front and this is just an image of a
neighboring development to give it some
context so the recommendation is for
approval subject to section 106 to
secure the affordable housing as well as
transport costs for the primary school
and also a secondary school transport
thank you very much
questions from members and near the
stage just can't staff it
um could you just turn your mic on so
sorry there it says Tara three four says
less than eight hundred meters from the
center of orly fourth one says
approximately 375 meters from the center
of oli the distance the footpath says 30
meters in two three four
he says 65 meters in for one the feeling
outraged it says something different
again perhaps I can't find that I just
wonder what the correct distances are I
know the - the footpath from Mill fields
is approximately I think it's ten
there's my ten meters it's about 30
meters I'm not sure any others by only
two seconds
[Music]
so we don't really know I'm sure they're
all fairly short but it's just a
documentation should be accurate for
instance is a farce race is the bus
stops a hundred meters of body in the
center pole so have so three different
figures within a page
[Applause]
we will yeah I mean obviously let's just
we'll measure that but obviously three
four and four one contradict each other
should be we need to have the accurate
yeah it's not a big issue but it we
should have it the paper should all have
one figure and so we'll just measure
that and we'll keep going with questions
counts for man sir thank you I've got a
couple of queries on both the indicative
plan and okay we're gonna have to wait
because there's one officer he's now
desperately trying to get the distance
so just bear with us a sec I thought it
was a general one we might have to cover
it with other people to the local board
members have any inside information on
the distance by a hundred meters can we
tell you that as given you happy yeah
okay I think we'll we'll take we'll take
that figure unless we hear otherwise
yeah the bus stop is obviously it some
people map so I'm not gonna be a hundred
inaccurate the distance to you from
roughly where the slight access is to
the footpath from Mill fields would be
about sixty five and then the bus stop
is the opposite side of the road from
Mill fields so you're looking at about
100 meters okay back to you counts
announcer thank you on both the
indicated plan layout and on page 116
which I believe is the responsible
strategic planning there is a proposed
housing mix and whilst this is an
outline applications that any way that
this means anything is well I'll say
there and my other question is on page
77 our list of conditions
could you please enlighten me as to what
a renewal integration scheme is on the
bottom right on the last bullet point on
page 100 up by page 77
pick up on the house I make sure you
look at little atoms so the housing mix
in terms of the afford Redux itself
would be secured by the 106 in terms of
the open market housing there is a
condition one up from the bottom on page
77 market housing mix brighter or
concurrent with reserve matters to be
agreed so we would expect to secure that
at that time so the the last paragraph
for patient and tender conditions energy
and renewal integration scheme to agree
that things like I'll see the electric
vehicle charging points because at the
moment it's reserved matter outline only
with only the access there's no details
of potentially any sustainable measures
for the site so it would be looking at
including electrical charging points and
potentially any throw again and so on
yeah I mean I've never come across the
term renewal integration it's a
beneficial term because it it it I
understand what you're saying when
you've explained it to me but I don't
understand why that is called renewal
integration but that's just as an aside
it's a specific reason why it stated
that take it on board and next time just
have a renewable energy okay any other
questions yes Chester Swift both
um switch boxes installation ahead short
printing are they standard conditions
I'm glad they're there where they come
from they don't have to be standard
conditions it's partly because of the
site location in terms of C to the north
and east you do have our agricultural
fields and again it goes down to or sea
and biodiversity and trying to see is
not only mitigate but in enhance
biodiversity in new developments and so
that's the reason for them yep there's
also a swift swift box scheme in Hawley
so they've been setting up Swift boxes
throughout Hawley from the church and on
houses through the streets so they've
been encouraging Swift it's for the last
couple of years yeah I think is
excellent and classes should be a
standard conditioning and developments
in villages castle wall boys I'm just
seeking a little bit of clarification
here it's about the affordable housing I
in that the actual percentage of a photo
browser is obviously very important to
this application but the the the notes
about the the large proportion of larger
dwellings whereas the the said the data
for Hawley says that many properties are
under occupied and one of the affordable
housing is integrated in the scheme and
not placed in one area and the Third
Point which is its page one would six is
about suitable housing options for more
held early people is that a definite
part of the planning application that
those points are going to be adopted or
is it just an expression of a
desirability for the affordable housing
so through the section 106
we literally secure the numbers so where
it says at the bottom of page 116 the
mix affordable rent for two bedrooms one
three bedroom that would be the part
that is secured specifically through the
one
six through the reserved matters would
be the location of those so we would
expect at that point it to be integrated
across the site have that mix have the
tenure blindness through the site that
that would be part of reserved letters
because it's designed and layout so we
would have to come back to that specific
part any other questions
no okay now so move on we don't have any
further comments performance in the
paper from the first count so we don't
have an objector we don't have a
supporter we don't have the applicant
but we have the board members counselor
Eber and then counsel willing
thank you very much chair and well the
disappointing the applicant isn't here
today so because for wireless site has
been included a neighborhood plan it's
disappointing that the applicant has
actually engaged with the community
prior to the application coming to a
committee and I'd hope that they would
be here today but they're not but
hopefully they will do so fully if this
application is approved there's a few
issues that we've got with this outline
application and some of your questions
have highlighted them so far
one is the housing mix another with
trees and open spaces and the third is
the entrance to the village so dealing
with the housing mix first the
indicative housing mix isn't
representative of that housing need for
Hawley there's a need as I've shown in
the in your papers for one bed housing
not for five bed housing and I'm very
concerned that this goes ahead with the
current layout without that need for bed
housing being included in an addictive
layout I'd also like to see a condition
that the affordable housing is for local
need first because we have got quite a
considerable local need and it's been
shown that on previous sites within the
village where it has gone for local need
they've developed their own community
very quickly in those streets and it's
it's proven to work well so I'd like to
see the mix changed and
removing the four bed and five bed homes
within the addictive layout there was a
several areas of open space and I think
care needs to be taken about to ensure
that these open spaces can be
well-managed and given that this site is
right on the edge of fields and there is
a considerable hedgerow along the
frontage and on side of the hot site at
the moment that in order to prove
improve the link to the countryside
those open spaces should be include
trees and planted across the side and
finally there 30 Molinaro is right on
the edge of this site up at the edge of
the close that's opposite of is close
and so such you hit the 30-mile
immediately at that's at the site and I
think given that highways haven't made
any objections
something kind of rounding sort of
Gateway treatment so does the entrance
to the village he needs to be done still
highlight that you're coming up to kind
of a new development and I'd like to see
something to put in place to to mitigate
that
but with those three key areas given
that this site is in the neighborhood
plan and the village have said this is
where they'd expect to see development
then it would expect it would be
approved thank you okay let's just pick
up on the point just so we don't get
confused about the market housing mix
etc because you've raised that can you
just clarify it for us exactly where we
stand on that because if you look at the
bottom of page 77 does say market
housing mix prior to or concurrent with
reserve matters to be agreed that's
right so in terms of what we're looking
at today is outline for up to 29 so that
is the extent of what we are saying yes
to is that they could put up to 29
houses on there the actual mix the
layout design print that that is all for
later
and that condition specifically means
that they will have to come and agree
the mix with us so that at that point we
can consult our housing colleagues and
sir Kate yes so the chief what we would
need them to or actually no they've gone
enthrall massive houses that's not
appropriate so that would be
that condition yeah Thank You chair but
it does say on the third bullet point of
the condition layout so broadly conform
to that shown on the alliterative
drawing so you know we're either
agreeing and kind of roughly what's
there or not it's broadly in terms of I
see the green space and the layout into
in terms of where the actual affordable
houses go there's no specific
designation in this and ultimately I
mean you know if if that condition isn't
put on it it can change but it was more
that most people and the council seemed
to support what was in front of him the
parish council and therefore it was
considered that this would be
appropriate going forward but a final
design will also evolve hopefully with
the reserve Nash's sorry I just wants us
to be clear what we're agreeing today so
should we just hear from councilor well
em and then we'll take a little
questions at the end
Council one Thank You chair yes
the parish council have supported this
application and I support the principle
of it but I've got a few concerns one of
those is that the property's opposite at
the site our bungalows are now slightly
lower land so I wonder if we could ask
the developer to consider putting
bungalows at the front of their site if
when that comes through on the and the
details of reserved matters there's a
number of small areas of open space on
there which are concern to me because
Hill one larger area rather Lots a
little bit would be more useful there
could be difficulties with managing a
little bit of open space so there needs
to be some care thought about any
approval of these lots of little bits
that there will be a proper management
scheme for them and the area but
potentially the larger area of public
open space at the front I would like to
see some trees they're not huge trees
because of the bungalows opposite but
some smaller trees perhaps
fruit trees with some separate varieties
of apple and so on yeah the affordable
house l think Rachel's already mentioned
that concerns about that I see that on
the on the drawing which is page hundred
and twenty four there's a reference to
for number one bedroom apartments and
yet that's not that's not a
recommendation from page 71 there seems
to be a bit of mismatch there where the
the officer is saying that there's a
need for one and two bedroom dwellings
there's a low 20 applicants with local
connections looking with half of them
looking for one-bedroom accommodation
and then suggests a slightly different
mix of housing affordable housing so I'd
like to see that those one as
one-bedroom properties do come forward
for affordable rent a couple of other
concerns one is you know it's a matter
to be considered in the future and that
is that this site could be being
developed at the same time as two other
housing sites in Hawley and it's
important that that all three are taken
into account when discussing
construction management plan and I just
wondered if there is any potential for
off off road pedestrian route to towards
the school and to the town or to the
village center if that could be
considered at some point but on the
whole I support the application as have
the neighbourhood plan working group of
the village and the parish council thank
you
I think it's important point so can
someone share that share that with a
quitter
okay so the the figures you were looking
at within the actual committee report on
page 116 roughly that's the they're the
comments from our strategic housing
department so there that's what they're
specifying or suggesting needs to be put
forward or seeing in section 106 in
terms of what's being provided in the
PowerPoint presentation at the back
would be indicative site site layout
that is merely the agents suggestion of
what they might be bringing forwards it
doesn't mean that that's what they will
do it will be up to you or see what's
negotiated and down into the section 106
the strategic housing at mid Suffolk has
not gone for the ten that are shown on
page 124 we've gone for the seven that's
on one one six that's what after housing
team is saying is needed for the village
their chair there's an inconsistency
between what the the statements made by
the strategic housing manager and
there's no logic to having come up with
that particular mix because in paragraph
four point two on page one one six she
says that the current registered need
for affordable housing in Hawley is 20
applicants with local connection with
over half looking for one-bedroom
accommodation and then her
recommendation does not include any
one-bedroom accommodation so it would
appear that the suggestion put forward
or the current registered need have been
taken into account by the applicant but
not by the specialist so let's check up
on that so more than that we can take
that away and confirm that with a
strategic housing the
the actual mix they definitely want is
having regard to the fact that there is
this one bedroom requirement and that
will retake that advice and that would
be on the basis of which we then follow
through with the section 106 agreement
will confirm that every members are
happy for us to do that on the basis
that on the basis that the application
is for the erection twenty nine houses
with ten affordable it was the mix to be
confirmed any yes count Samantha I never
yes really on questions yes I'm asking
questions about the because it was
mentioned by I think it was cancer even
about the boundary treatment and I just
wondered I do we have a picture of the
existing gateway into the village from
that direction
to see what it looks like now because
obviously you're gonna bring me housing
forward and I wondered what it look like
now I can't quite visualize it we do it
just bring it up
slide 16
forgetting that technology
[Laughter]
it's coming by fax so that's the site
more or less where the trees are so
that's Millfield in the distance on the
right-hand side but this don't mean it's
a site here they'll be a footpath coming
along so there's a hedgerow at the
moment which will obviously remain along
here but it will be quite visual
potentially depending on I'll see any
landscaping that comes in at a later
stage okay so so the point has been made
about coming into the village and the
landscape and when would that be secured
and when would that be condition now or
in there well you can secure some of it
by condition but in terms of reserve
matters that would for you when it comes
forward and hopefully almost discussion
prior to a reserved matters application
where we can work with the agent to
secure scheme can Sofia I think it was
really that last point we've got
conditions on Swift boxes and hedgehogs
don't we add the one on boundary
treatment to be agreed with some sort of
comment to replace the existing
hedgerows is it there so I'm sorry I
didn't resign the conditions yeah yeah
I've already covered and what about the
village gateway that the local members
were requesting is that possible - I do
that at some point so I think a bullet
point on the we just want the the as
it's the entrance to the village to be
further details to be provided something
like that can we have a condition that
that's how we word it I'll leave that to
you okay something along the fact that
it is the entrance point to the vich I
mean it's not it's it's not in the
middle of it of the entrance point so
that's going to be very it's important
of that
well choreographed for the people
driving in they see what's happening
okay any other yes council war boys
dozen for me I think the final cut on
the constraints map there's a an
overhead power line running diagonally
across the site which is no doubt why
perhaps it was excluded from the
original plans for for development how
would this be taken into account by the
development
I mean there be various options in terms
of undergrounding moving it and that
would be up to them at that point if
that power line is still there and we
come in for reserved matters and it goes
across the houses there is a whole other
issue that we would have to then
consider at that point whether that were
to be appropriate but I think given the
location of this site there should be
other options that the developer could
explore to move all through it as it
underground it find an alternative to
allow that layout to go forward but said
if it weren't to have happened or be
resolved at the point of reserved
matters that would be a consideration
and we would have to make that view of
of whether the layout would be
appropriate having regard for the
parallel though basically it would come
back and they'll have to have a solution
or no solution but then that would be
before members when it Nick next come
back and be for us to determine whether
that's appropriate or not
any other questions no ok so we've had
all the information put the force we've
heard from the ward members thank you
both for joining us today and it's a
velocity discuss the base and come to a
conclusion on this yeah Cass afield I
thought it quite refreshing to come to a
an application that actually is in line
with the neighborhood plan adverse to it
that we've got a layout which there's an
agreement that what these achieve should
broadly conform to that so we're we're
not agreeing allowed to make believe
it's it's something that's reasonably
well defined they do seem to be these
requirements okay on the boundaries
Swift boxes etc things that people are
concerned about and there seems to be
sufficient flexibility to perhaps to
agree that the housing
as we go forward in accordance with
local requirements I have to sour
personally I'm always a bit concerned
about too many one-bedroom houses
because that's during perhaps by the
bedroom tax which could will evaporate
very shortly so but nevertheless that's
what the current position is and we do
have energy with new or more integration
schemes so it does seem that this is in
line with what we need and what the
local population requires so on that
basis I support it and I actually would
look I was approval man so thank you
Aria I am really pleased that we have
both energy sustainability and rainwater
harvesting mentioned in the conditions
and I really hope that this is the way
we're going to go forward as a council
because it's fantastic that we are
mentioning it in our list of conditions
so I'm really pleased to see that I too
refreshed by the fact that we have here
we have an application that the parish
counts so in the neighbourhood plan are
supporting albeit is outside of the
existing red line and it's not even in
our proposed you know our draft joint
local plan as part of the settlement
boundary but it does seem like a fairly
logical extension to the village and I I
share it counts the Welland's comment
about the off road walking route because
I know there is a sort of unofficial
footpath along the back of that site and
it would be great if if that could be
sort of incorporated it does look like
that the indicative layout there is a
bit of open space up there so that it's
not like it's attached to somebody's
private garden and I think so long as we
can we can tighten up the the whatever
it's called boundary treatment on that
exposed entrance to the village because
it is like at the top of the hill and
you're coming down from you know you
come down and you see that you see Holly
and and then you go down the hill into
the into the central village so it is
going to be quite prominent so a strong
stop bullet point about the the
landscaping making sure that's right and
I agree with cancer field that we do
have something
disability about making sure the housing
mixes right so I'm prepared to second
counts the fields proposal
thank you very much just before we go on
there's nothing proposed second I'm just
going to get that bullet point read out
regarding the entrance to the village
that we'd add to the recommendations
yeah thank you I wanted to run through
that so we've got the recommendation on
page 77 that we are also agreeing the
mix of affordable housing there is also
the travel costs that the officered
mentioned earlier for school travel
across that we added 4 minus 6 and then
what are we looking to take an
additional condition for a scheme to be
agreed for the village entrance point
does that cover what members were
seeking okay does anyone else yes that's
the map I am slightly concerned that the
developers haven't engaged at the
village they haven't turned up today is
there anything we can do to make sure
that when further detail comes back we
actually get a chance to talk to thee
not ours although we always encourage
all developers to engage fully the
community because you get a better
application you get better engagement
you get better buying and actually here
this is the opportunity for them to
discuss what they're proposing and it's
a good opportunity to showcase their
application it is disappointing they
have chosen not to I agree anyone else
wish to speak no okay so it's been
proposed by councillor field and
seconded by Councillor maths or as per
the recommendations on page 77 and 78 of
our papers with the additional points
that Gemma's has touched on all those in
favor of the recommendation that's
unanimous thank you very much propose we
start to get it at 5 to 11 just for a
comfort break
if that's okay
you
[Music]
so welcome back everyone
the next application before us is DC
1903 191 in I never Tommaso to present
I've gone on the wrong one very sorry
we're silly nice sorry yeah 7d the next
application is DC 1903 834 also an i and
over to you must thank you very much
hello everyone so this application is
also situated in I thank you this
application is for a section 73
variation of two conditions of the
original plan application which was
approved in 2017 the two conditions
restricted the public access to the
touchdown offices the offices are owned
by MIT Suffolk District Council and is
used by offices every day from 8:00 in
the morning till 8:00 in the evening the
current application varies the
conditions to allow for public access
between 9:00 and 3:00 in the afternoon
three days a week on Wednesdays
Thursdays and Fridays I give you one
moment to just have read
the application is situated in I outside
of the conservation area
no heritage issues we're identified as
you can see the flashing lightest shows
the shows the location of a touchdown
office it is within the residential call
de sac taken close no pop no parking has
been proposed as part of this
application same as the previous
approval there are however two public
car parks near to the side within walk
walking distance this is just the
context of the site and where it is so
the two and the two hatched red red line
outlines the public car park the
officers currently use these car parks
for the future for the members of public
this is also applicable that's the
location of the office in relation to a
public car park
as you can see it's a small office and
there's limitations to the number of
people who could visit at each given
time and office is considered it given
declare public and social benefits in us
working in collaboration with the town
council this should be approved it is
within the walking distance it's it is
intended for the people in I says for
the local people to use this office and
these are some photos of the side there
will be some increase in pedestrian
movement there will be no vehicle
movements increase in a close but in
terms of amenity of the neighbors
officers consider that this will not be
significant as to raise any issues in
terms of amenity there's no anticipation
intensification in terms of operation no
businesses have been proposed so it's a
limited number of people on controlling
controlled manner and controlled hours
of three days a week between certain
hours who would be coming to the office
to Cedar Town Council the town Clark so
based on information given to your
members we consider that this should be
who proved the font is too small but we
can read it so basically the only
difference between the previous approval
it's just there laughs with public
access three days a week between 9:00
and 3:00 in the afternoon
thank you just quickly pick up on
something in the recommendation which is
we've reiterated the time limiting
condition to unnecessarily on page 172
we've got it in twice and that shouldn't
be part of the recommendation process so
we've got the section 73 time limit
which is firing but condition to another
three is so suggest we just remove
bullet point two master would you just
double-check if you look at page I have
1972 one is fine and then two you
iterate it essentially given them a
fresh three years which we wouldn't that
wouldn't be what we'd need to do okay
happy where that is yes please yes dude
please ignore daddy that's right slide
thank you any questions yes Custer
feared because even
so it's just one memories gone a little
since I last sat through this particular
application in 2017 was it I just
wondered whether you could to refresh my
memory what sort of residents are there
in the housing that surrounds this
particular X common room for a sheltered
housing scheme so you so you have any
particular different characteristics
like majority of our perhaps well yeah
thing
and when you've answer that you you
certainly our particular staff can be
told very clearly to go parked somewhere
else rather than in this particular
clothes and all you control the for how
you guys of the people who are visiting
the town council and well as I
understand what Town Council would
operate had they operate but they
clearly have let's well I'm led to
believe that people are aware that there
is no parking available within the close
and I have included the previous
committee report in the bundle which you
know explains the issues of parking
previously it was extensively explored
and it was resorted that you know the
resolution was for everyone to be
parking at the public car park and like
I said there's a number of his limited
number of people who would be tending
the office at each given time given the
size of the office and hours of
operation and days of the operation but
as far as I know there's no change in
the parking at all Peter is the living
in our and the board member do you want
to just to tell us anymore and the
question that's been asked thank you
Thank You chair in terms of the the
impact of this this application now when
we're talking about allowing public
access but actually we're talking about
one two three
as a week visit in the office so it's
not it's it's very marginal impact in
terms of the number of people and you've
got fourth the office in operation three
days a week you would have one one
person there most of that most of that
time and as the officer has said the the
it's very close to off street parking so
that's what I would expect to happen I
can certainly talk to the clerk to make
sure that happens but now I know that
that will be the case temperature of
your first question I know that this is
part of a a review of sheltered
accommodation before my time as a
counselor yes and do family memory or
not we'll probably know more about that
than I do what I would say is part of
the context here we are
the town council is working with
officers from mid Suffolk and Suffolk to
look at in the longer term alternative
accommodation for office and perhaps
some other services as well that would
allow in the longer term and I know it's
not part of this proposal these premises
to be returned to some kind of
residential he's gonna veer us off that
because we can only look at what yes
yeah yeah okay thank you John you want
to come back with me to come back here
mate you may have noticed from the
previous record that I did propose with
refusal of this in originally and my
concerns were that this is a sheltered
housing scheme and they often
accommodate vulnerable people to go I
was sitting next to last night shelters
scheme or yesterday was it was 97 you
know
they're elderly people with some
concerns and there is you know so you
don't want control very division yeah
that's not going to debate the debate
suspicions about the question was really
is it still a sheltered scheme we have
been closing those down in a way or the
ones that are out in the sticks have
been less used for sheltered combination
he might by now be just ordinary council
tenants and that was really the gist are
we aware it's a shelter so on a still
all right the housing now to best my
knowledge some of some of the properties
have been Dashell turd as part of that
earlier strategy and have canceled
tenants in them and some are still used
as sheltered provision though not
Suzanne says he mixes you understand
okay counselor man so did you have you a
handle cash we burned then you Thank You
chair I was gonna false gonna raise the
issue parking because I wouldn't if you
to get that close you drive down it and
you would park outside half on the
pavement and half in the road so I mean
that's what people will do they won't
park in the car park and walk there so
that needs to be considered but so I was
gonna raise say where we're up you know
where other is the parking but also do
we consider loan working as well as
point giving us a counseled property I
think I'm it's not a sits down to the
town council is for them to consider and
and I would have to say that businesses
debate but the town council with
requesting this to run their scheme and
if the Town Council suddenly rose
there's a parking problem I would have
think that town counts would be the
first one to hopefully get on top of it
and resolve it would be my guest but
counselor ma'am sir thank you I'd like
to first of all comment on page 167
where we have our reason for a reference
to committee and it it doesn't mention
the fact that it's owned by mid Suffolk
in there and I think perhaps it should
and my other query is it's a bit related
to the other crews about about parking
and I I just wonder if there's any scope
for putting something that you can lock
your bike to because I believe all
public buildings should have somewhere
to lock your bike to and I've just
looked at that photograph there's not
even a railing you know to try and
encourage people not to park down there
if they actually could cycle they're
going to go in for 10 minutes put lock
their bike to a railing or a bike rack
would be fantastic I think we can add
that if that's what the players and
seconded and I mean the idea is people
in I walked the Town Council you know I
mean it you would hope venya as for them
councillor anyone else was just
yes I would tend to agree I don't know
what that wasn't picked up and this is
it Suffolk who is there another reason
that it was brought was that just a
technical no that's just the technical
mister apologies for that which we
picked up future wasn't a parish council
in I there's a town council so in fact
the wording on that reasons for
reference is wrong it does look like
it's not being edited out okay anyone
else wish to speak no it's been it's now
over to us to discuss debate and come to
a conclusion I'm sorry please sir go
you've come all this way I say sorry
because he was smoking I've lost my
train of thought
Peter over to you as the as the ward
member sorry I'm very sorry
thank you this this is an application
it's been said by the by the Town
Council given given what said about the
building being in the ownership of of
mid Suffolk whether it's a who are
effectively the landlord had more bit of
enterprise then to get the town caster
pay for the planning application but
that's not a relevant matter yeah
the Town Council has to leave its
current accommodation on the 20th of
December where it is at the moment has
been taken over by home start so there's
a it needs to be accommodating being
talking to officers at mid Suffolk for
some time now about the possibility of
this these premises being used to
accommodate the the Town Council there
are benefits for that not least in terms
of encouraging a closer working between
the town and the district the impact of
this I think is is marginal so you're
talking about most of time one one
person working there three days a week
number of public visits as I said there
it is not great one and perhaps up to
three people a week typically to pay for
allotment or or whatever it might be and
the odd counselor visiting to see the to
visit the Clark
so the impact it is actually quite
heavily used at the moment by officers
of this council as a as a touchdown a
place I know that the building control
officer for the area uses it virtually
daily so it has quite a lot of officer
use already so I think there'll be rare
moments when the town Clark would be the
only person working
the site in terms of the point about
bicycles and those are very handy and
secure Lobby at part of the entrance to
the building where I would think a
bicycle or two could be could be
securely accommodated while people are
there or visiting the point is that we
all have a concern about provision of
sheltered accommodation and the need
that gives rise to two that I know again
not not germane to what's before us but
the upcoming neighborhood plan feride
makes makes a very considerable
provision or within that plan for
sheltered housing for the time really
chair that's all I have to say happy to
answer any further questions thank you
my apologies again for missing out any
questions at all yeah master master
thank you thank you thank you for
picking up my my query about site cycle
parking facilities and I'm I'm intrigued
about the use of the lobby because if I
was just remember the public visiting a
parish council office I wouldn't dream
of bringing my bike inside the building
unless there was a nice sign saying five
the storage available inside so I still
think it might be preferable if we can
have a braiding outside but English
let's go so your your function while
reading their bikes into some office it
may or may not be quite overcrowded and
it's a good point especially as I'm just
asking who would pay for it looks like
doubt I tank out I didn't what where
that goes
is that's just something we could ask
its looked at rather than
informative or whatever you call it you
mean yeah I think that would be
preferable cause looking at the red line
it's drawn very tightly around the
building and the implications of a
condition might be problematic but an
informative that we can put that under
review would seem appropriate thank you
yes so in so any other questions for the
ward member we're still in that yep
counselor field yes just could you
refresh my memory how big is on as a
town not for long
how big is it is it 2000 population
around there at the moment it's in 2011
census 2000 154 people any other
questions
no okay well thank you for that Peter so
we now move into discussion debate and
to reach a conclusion on this who would
like to kick-off kasih field and repeat
the things I said last time around
obviously this is the use of a building
which is semi redundant I think they
it's not used its use as a common room
stop some time ago so the cells they
were clearly good aspects to this and I
guess the Town Council doesn't need a
limited amount of commendation the
concerns already had whether it is in
the sheltered scheme and a lot of people
there are vulnerable you know in various
ways a way that you just don't want too
many people wandering around and
certainly don't want people driving cars
and parking them outside it disturbs the
residents one doesn't obviously want to
either play that too much but but you do
get they are the class of people who are
affected by various brands of Rogue
Traders quite often and so keeping such
individuals well away it's a good idea
and we do all have a so so guarding
responsibility so I guess that is the
the real issue
concerns me significantly in extending
this sort of use when we agreed the past
planning application as it was on the
basis that we didn't allow the general
public you know who obviously vary
widely in characteristics due to use the
accommodation we just allowed council
officers was a clearly under Anton's
role and and you know reasonable
individuals certainly the sheltered
accommodation you know there's a
syllabus in my County division and the
police have been making great points
about it be an open-plan and that it
should have boundary walls and gates and
God knows what else to keep these people
isolated and here we're actually
encouraging additional risk that way so
you know I personally am against this
use I'm not convinced that there's no
other alternatives you know one accepts
as I've you spoil it
the Clark himself I'm sure always a
responsible individual not so much a
problem someone who's gonna drive in
leave their car temporarily visit and
someone with unknown characteristics and
I think this is a risk that I personally
wouldn't want to die yeah fine I've got
I'd love to come back but I don't want
to lead from the chair so I'll leave
others first and I'll come up Castle
eben and Councilman don't think very
much chair um before before I start can
I just have a plea that we have the
correct planning papers this is a third
application today when we've got things
that aren't correct so for example page
189 refers to a planning application in
Norton so in a school close in Norton
which we're not looking at we're looking
up close it up on what those what 189
minutes from the meeting
I hadn't even noticed that yeah so so
could I just have a you know and
previous application we had incorrect
Pickers for distances and the previous
one we had you know just really pleased
can people double-check for these
applications before we get them and put
the correct information in but having
said that given that this is something
that I'd Town Council have asked for
I would assume therefore that they've
considered fully all the implications um
one of my slight concerns actually is
that these sort of touchdown points when
we originally said we were going to move
offices and have a head office you know
we we weren't gonna have any sort of it
the the out lying kind of what are now
called touchdown points seem to now
being used extremely heavily and so my
concern would be just that you know
you've got lots of good Suffolk officers
queuing up to kind of work there and the
desks are taken up by high Town Council
so just need to be sure that that space
is managed well and obviously there's
nothing here about how the space is
going to be managed and whether lies
paying for I thought of the space around
how it's working out but I would just
ask that that's really carefully
considered and especially if officers
say from mid Suffolk Oh ranging to meet
someone from the public there to build
control meeting a developer obviously
that's outside those hours and I do
slightly agree with my colleague
counselor field that there will be
traffic down that road of individuals
going down the road and through a chose
accommodations or do have a slight
concern about that but overall given the
I town council have asked for it I would
be supportive for this thank you can we
just touch on about the public access
yeah well yes the office is used
regularly it's not used heavily so
there's only one or two offices at a
time who attend the office like I said
there's there's so much of scope for
that office it's a smaller space however
and we have been in discussion with
regards to how this space will be
subdivided and that's false coming
so we have considered all the aspects
before we came to this conclusion so I
just wanted to make that point clear
nose for the for the Town Council and
for for the Town Council and the offices
to be able to work even if like you said
there is a confidential meeting that is
you know being held in the office and
ensuring that there are no conflicts so
to speak but that's forthcoming nirmala
J I'm certainly listen to what talk -
case - field case or even a said but I'm
pretty certain that I Town Council will
have a risk assessment undertaken before
there's any lone working in the
parameters purely for health and safety
someone's taken ill individual cetera
but as there are several people working
there anyway I don't think that be well
there is gonna be pretty low and the
fact that you've already said that
there's only two or three visitors a
week so personally I am supportive of
this application so I will be supporting
it so I'm the same as counsel and
whether I mean we talk about public
sector sharing space we talk about
having a one public sector of state we
talk about working better together this
to me is exactly what we should be doing
with our buildings get better usage and
this is a really good example I really I
know I mean I tag Council has always
been very much at the forefront of
looking after the residents of I and I'm
absolutely sure they thought there was
any threat to the sheltered housing or
anything else like that they would have
thought about that and would have
thought about maybe trying to find
another venue if they thought there was
a threat so you know I I have confidence
I am just going to come back I'm afraid
to the papers you know we have had a
series of papers today that are all
wrong and we need some way of checking
it because you know we can't have
opening paragraphs on reference for
committee that cannot be wrong the odd
paper slipped in by mistake is fine and
we can't have recommendation we can't
have you know not known distances from
the town to a site that is just simple
stuff so we need to are can i you know
actually put on the minutes that you
know that needs someone needs to look at
the papers
detail we shouldn't be picking up stuff
like that please so no one else has
spoken and so I'm happy to propose if I
don't normally do that but Cal so having
him do you want to go I'm sure I can
sort of thought about this and you know
I've done the risk assessment so I'm
happy to propose it masa masa and happy
to second descent yep
by all means if I'm allowed to say that
I mean with the with the concerns raised
by by some of my colleagues is there any
potential for making this a temporary
permission or does it have to be
permanent you could decide to make it
tender but you really need to be
satisfied that's there's a good planning
purpose for doing so right you know
planning balances and planning for
planning reasons but it's obvious it's
up to a community if there are if there
are some concerns about the increased
footfall and car usage down the close
where the sheltered units are is that
not a planning reason that you want to
make monitor the amount of disturbance I
mean I don't know I mean of course it's
up to the committee to decide but the
only but the Town Council know resident
and the ward member have not raised that
as a concern at all so if you feel it
needs to be a concern that's up to you
when we come to vote if you feel that
way council war boys
it's I agreed the principal has been
raised about sort of putting our
officers out into the communities and
working at a distance I'm just as just
as Megan thought at the recommend work
as to whether this is future proof I I
is destined to grow enormous leap
next decade
there's already a at times congestion
during car parks and facilities within
the Tai Center and this site is very
constrained whether there'd be a need
for it to be moved to a larger premises
in the future not aware this allows for
expansion is its to be a concern afraid
that's not what's before us today that's
not relevant to today's application all
we're being asked to decide is what's
before us which is the existing site
becoming a facility for three afternoons
a week if you want to comment on that by
all means you can but it's not really a
big toad this that's not really relevant
to the application if it becomes
outgrown and they would have to put
another planning application in foot to
move it or to expand it so it's been
proposed by accounts are handing them I
don't have a seconder councillor Miller
happen to second so its proposed as per
the recommendation on page 172 with
bullet point two taken out but with the
information note that appropriate bike
storage is please considered all those
in favor of the recommendation seven
days against one okay thank you very
much and we now move on to stow markets
and Peters DC 1904 eight six nine and
over to Harry to present the application
thank very much chair so here we have an
application at the former Poundland site
in keeping waiting Stowe market is a
full plan application the part change of
use of an a.1 unit to a gym which falls
under D to use class including
alterations to the entrance door so here
is the site location plan so it is
located centrally within Stowe market
with the station located to the east
just off the edge of the slide there we
have the constraints map showing the
site is located outside outside flood
zone 2 and 3 it is not listed however
there is some listed buildings nearby
however the Heritage team have raised no
objections to his proposal so the site
is located within the conservation area
however see with it being existing it's
already there the aerial map has the
site there obviously
hatched is the element that is to be
changed in its use so is a large retail
unit with a large carpark to the front
so the entire site has a square meter
each of a 1145 square meters and the
existing car parts at the front has 76
car parking spaces the obviously with
the block plan it shows the proposed
unit being subdivided with alterations
to the access there with the red arrow
the proposed gym unit is to take up 694
square meters of the unit with the
remainder being left in a 1u Shekhar's
so we have the existing elevations and
the proposed elevations obviously
showing the extent alterations including
which include the insertion of sorry the
insertion of bi-folding doors to the
front the proposed signage for the
application doesn't fall within this
will be submitted under a separate
application so then we just have some
floor plans showing the existing ground
floor and they proposed with the
subdivision in place so the floor plate
is to include free weights and activity
area a functional area changing rooms
that a large gym floor area itself and
associate facilities including changing
rooms and staff areas and then we have
some site photos obviously your unit
currently is redundant and has no
businesses occupying it and that's such
that location has come forward we have
the application is recommended for
approval subject to conditions including
the standard time approved plans cycle
spaces being provided and the gym being
limited to d2 use only with no changes
to that use coming forward without
applying application right thank you
very much questions at this point
nope okay so we move on we don't have
anyone from the town council we don't
have an object to support all the
applicant and the ward member is paul
opinion he is sent in the following
unfortunately our neighbor
sorry unfortunately I will otherwise be
engaged so not be able to attend this
meeting in person I was hired at the
state market Town Council planning
meeting with this application is
considered and voted in favor of it then
as district councillor Ward member I'm
in favor of granting this application
for the economic social and health and
well-being reasons that have been
highlighted and respected the latter of
these reasons perhaps another
consideration could be for there to be
installed a defibrillator on the
premises this is there is a recognition
that more of these we have around the
town would be better kind regards Paul
so members that's it that's all the
information before us time to debate
counselor straight off Thank You chair I
too supported this application when it
came before the Planning Committee its
toe markets and council and I fully
support it now this particular site has
been a formerly been an Aldi store a
family bargains and a parent LAN and
they have all failed because the
shoppers do not tend to go to that site
very often for shopping just the parking
so rather than see is empty I totally
support it and would recommend approval
counts adding it yeah I'm like Dave I'd
like to see this site being used and so
I'm happy to second it thank you
just I'm just curious here so it says
mid suffer District Council owns the
site but do we own the building
I mean does that mean I mean who
presumably pounded and built the
building or the people before pounded
and yeah I might be wrong but I believe
that Smith suffered bought the building
with the car park
yeah pretty certainly key chairing so as
a lack of knowledge yes I saw another
hand go up
can't some answer thank you yes I
although I'm not a fan of a gin I think
it's actually quite quite good you've
got a gym in the center of town because
it is actually accessible by sustainable
means of transport being spitting
distance from the station and bus stops
and the fact you're going to provide
another 17 bike racks or whatever in the
center of town and I you know I can't
wear anything but support it although if
people did actually walk from the
station and the bus stop and then used
their buy perhaps they wouldn't need to
pay for gym membership but that's their
business so yeah I I'm going to support
this because I think it is in the
sustainable location and as has been
said by my colleagues you know retail
premises don't seem to have done
particularly well there so and it's good
to see this building put back into use
rather than sitting there empty so good
luck to them calves are feared
yes sir just to agree that this seems to
be part of the transition away from
reach out for a masses in town centers
so it's a move to be supported and
hopefully a case has helped from behind
the business right so it'll be an a
financial benefit as well that's
probably prejudicial isn't it yes so I
likewise will support this although
there isn't curry restaurant right
opposite and every time I go there I
will now feel very guilty looking at a
Big Jim sign and that but of course this
is all very positive for the town it's
good to use the space and and bring
something forward to what is an unused
space can we just ask one question
quickly d2 in the recommendation because
the thing about d2 is that could then
become other things so are we just
saying we're permitting this use or
we've committing d2 so it will just be
the gym use and it will be limited to
that through a condition but if any
other changes does come forward it will
require an application like okay thank
you
oh that could slow fast because it you
burn accounts an answer
yeah so chair just just on that note
look looking at the layout of the gym on
that that wasn't a cafe or any kind of
space like that where often you do have
most spaces would that be permissible
within that current use or or if they
wanted to bury that with earlier and
have to come back with something else so
it would depend on the extent of that if
it was ancillary ie a very small amount
so if they had a coffee bar for example
made with three seats
we'd consider that ancillary if that
goes beyond and becomes a significant
proportion less floor space we'd
consider that to be a change of use but
they have a a small degree of
flexibility for some of those extra
parts if they need it now Samantha I
noticed while we're looking at the
recommendation that there's nothing
about hours of business and I wonder if
that is relevant whether there is any
restriction to when they can open
so the gym has been proposed to open
24/7 and so yeah it's it will be open
yeah unless members feel there's a
planning reason that that should be
restricted if it was in the middle of
housing or something like that and you
felt that was a problem but I think yeah
in this location I mean I don't think
there are any residential properties
nearby but please correct me if I'm
wrong do you want to come in and advise
us casa milà Thank You Chet there are
some residential properties quite close
by to the gym and is proposed to open it
24/7 as it estate in the papers however
I can't see that would be a great
problem the building will be supervised
at all time by staff and to be honest I
might be wrong it's purely subjective
but I can I'll see there's gonna be a
great deal of movement during the
nighttime hours this place okay so it's
been proposed by councillor Miller has
been seconded by Councillor having them
as in the recommendations on page two
one for about papers all those in favor
of the recommendation can have a share
pounds base that's unanimous
thank you very much so that just leaves
me to wish everyone a very Merry
Christmas and best wishes for the new
year and see you all in January